so we've now drawn pictures of the
interaction of a person jumping off a
cart in both the ground frame and a
reference frame moving with velocity VC
which is the final speed of the cart
these were pictures in the reference
frame moving with VC and these are the
pictures momentum diagrams of the person
in the cart in the ground frame now we
would like to apply the momentum
principle to solve for VP and VC we are
given that the relative velocity of the
person in the moving frame you will
treat this as a given quantity and will
express the velocity VC and so we want
to find BC and VP in terms of U MP and
MC now we'll use the ground frame first
and our assumption here is that the
person jumped horizontally and that
there are no external forces in the
horizontal direction so all of the
vectors we've drawn are horizontal and
there's no external forces in the
horizontal direction then we know that
the initial momentum of the system is
equal to the final momentum of the
system in our initial picture nothing is
moving and in our final picture we have
M cart D cart plus M person B person is
0 now recall that we also showed that
the velocity of the person in the ground
frame is related to the velocity of the
person in the moving frame by adding the
relative velocity of the two frames the
relative velocity of the two frames is
the velocity of the car BC so what we
have is VC plus u so this is how VP is
related to you and now I can use this
start equation to write it as zero
equals MC VC plus MP x vc plus u and by
adding terms
I get that MC plus MP v C equals minus
MP u or the velocity of the cart is
equal to minus MP u divided by MC plus
MP now that I have the velocity of the
cart I can just substitute that in here
to find the velocity the person which
remember was the velocity of the cart
Plus u so now I've solved this problem
in the ground frame next I'll do the
same analysis in the moving frame